Here are the rules of the game.
This is Sam.
Hi, from Wendover Productions,
Half as Interesting, and
especially Jet Lag: The Game.
And today, we are gonna
get taken to about
five or ten minutes' distance
apart in Central London.
The first to take a photo
of the other one
and send it in the group chat wins.
On the phone are Ben and Adam,
also from Jet Lag: The Game.
They're gonna be our handlers.
They're gonna tell us
where to go,
and while we can we can hide,
we can duck and dive a bit,
we can't go in a direction
to find someone
or avoid someone
without their say-so.
Right, you ready?
Yeah, let's do it.
Alright, we're going.
Three.
Two.
One.
Let's go.
Which way do I go?
Alright, you're gonna wanna
start by going north,
but I also don't want us to
just have you go
straight towards him, right?
We're gonna need to be strategic,
but I would start off
heading north on, I believe
it's called Farringdon Street.
Is that a street that is there?
No, I see New Bridge Street and
I see Queen Victoria Street.
Okay, that's fascinating.
(both laughing)
Just head north...
away from the river.
Okay.
I really think we have to
draw Tom to a big open space.
'Cause that's gonna be
the easiest area
to nab him in the photo
while we can hide.
And especially thinking about ones
that he can't really sneak around.
Yes, okay, so you're
near kind of two fields.
You're near Gray's Inn Gardens...
which is right north of you.
Okay.
and you're also near
Lincoln's Inn Fields,
which is right to the
west of you.
Okay, so Gray's Inn is bigger,
so we should go to that maybe.
So Tom, my thought on
the best way to do this
is that these trackers
show location,
like in an XY sense,
but they don't show height.
So if there's any way that you
can get to an elevation differential,
I think that that would be
enough to throw them off...
and potentially get us a pic.
Elevation differential.
I mean, I can do that.
There's a set of stairs
directly to the right of me
that go up somewhere,
but I feel like they'll
have the high ground,
'cause they're gonna
come in that way.
You'll wanna get closer for sure.
Okay, I'll bear that in mind.
Which way do you want me to go?
Keep going north.
They're a good ways north.
Yeah, I think we gotta
take advantage of the fact
that I think I'm gonna be
faster moving than Tom.
Both because he has a
backpack on, and I don't.
And because I'm taller,
I have longer legs and stuff.
So let's use speed as an advantage.
Oh, Tom is moving quite quickly.
He's moving quite quickly
towards you.
You may be wrong.
Tom might be faster
than you thought.
He's very powerful.
He's a very powerful foe
and you should be very scared.
Is he just trying to wear me out
so I have to come to him?
'Cause I'm pretty sure...
I'd say it's very hard to
tell what he is trying to do.
So it looks like you're north.
You should be passing
Ludgate Hill, right?
Yep, I've just gotta wait until I've
got the green light to cross.
This is good enough.
You can also take a left.
You know what, why not
take a left onto Fetter Lane?
A left?
Because north is so predictable.
Yeah, take a left.
Okay.
Okay, you should be near
Gray's Inn Gardens now.
Can you see them?
They should be to your left.
There's a big— There's a wall.
Again, I don't know
if this is a place
that you're allowed to go to.
(lackadasical grumbling)
Let's learn about Gray's Inn Gardens.
Yeah, let's learn about
Gray's Inn with more expediency.
You sound too relaxed, Ben!
Oh, it looks beautiful!
I'm in the thick of it!
It's closed.
Yeah, it looks beautiful— What?
It opens at 12 pm.
On Monday.
It's 2:36— on Monday?!
This GPS is not good at
telling me the name of streets.
Oh, that's gonna work
really well for us, cool(!)
Yeah, it's gonna be
really great, I think(!)
Take a right.
Okay, that's where I'm going.
No, a left.
What? That's the other direction!
You got stuck with
the wrong guy.
Take a left.
I'm allowed to wait for
three minutes without moving.
And then I have to move on.
Okay.
So do I just wait here and...
hang around and wait
for them to approach?
I would...
Yeah, why don't we
give them a minute,
and why don't we also
have a quick chat
about potential plans
that they might have,
and ways that we can
subvert them?
So I think one thing we're
gonna want to avoid
is we never want a situation where
we're in the middle of a street,
and they're coming around
the corner onto that street.
'Cause I think that that's
gonna give an advantage.
Agreed, we want the corners.
I'm gonna bring you down
towards Lincoln's Inn Fields.
There's a gazebo in the center
and there are paths around it,
and there's a building or—
So it looks like a public park.
It's like a public park, yeah.
I think that this might be a
good space to catch them.
Tom is also sort of
heading that direction.
He's heading towards
Lincoln's Inn Fields.
But he's still south of it.
I wonder if he's also gone
for the defensive strategy.
I wanna move towards Sam
as quickly as possible,
so they start to panic
and make bad decisions.
I think that that is a great plan.
Alright, which way, which way?
Let's go...
Let's see here.
I can go north up Shoe Lane, or
west or east on Fleet Street.
Why don't we go north?
Ben, one thing we need to
think about is if we do
end up trying to get him
in the park...
where should we be positioned
in the park to draw him across?
'Cause he's of course gonna
be conscious of the risk.
He's gonna know I'm there,
he's gonna be conscious
of the risk of going
across an open area.
So...
I'm running.
Do I need to run?
No, absolutely not.
There are lots of— There
appear to be lots of trees.
Okay.
So you think hiding within
the park is the best strategy?
I think hiding in the park
will probably work pretty well.
If I go north along
St. Andrew Street,
that meets what I think
is High Holborn
Yes, which is the street
at level, at grade.
they are headed towards
now, it appears.
Right, if I go northeast from
here along Shoe Lane,
that takes me to the bottom of—
that takes me underneath
High Holborn.
Now, I don't know if
there are stairs up there.
There might be.
So in theory I could pop
up
and see them there.
Yes. Yes.
Or they could—
I dunno whether that's
worth laying a trap.
I'm only allowed to stay in
one place for a few minutes.
Alright, let's put
some pressure on them.
Let's move towards them.
I love— We're not gonna
go to where they are
and try to get the picture yet,
but if they are forced to move
after this three minutes,
then I think that we'll
be in a good position
where then they might have
to start heading towards us.
Because they're
gonna use up their—
Oh wait, are they
on the move now?
No, they're moving now, okay.
Okay, which way?
They're moving down to High Holborn.
I think go up Shoe Lane.
Go northeast up Shoe Lane.
Try to get under High Holborn.
Roughly how far away is
Tom, like in distance?
Like a... quarter mile.
Quarter mile, okay,
so that's a good margin.
This is assuming there are
stairs to get me
between here on Shoe Lane
and up to High Holborn.
Let's see if there are.
No, there aren't!
There's no connection
between the two.
Damn!
Okay, okay. Things are
starting to get interesting.
I think you guys are about to be
basically on the same street.
I am wide open!
Find me a place to run to.
Okay, go...
Just go— Can you keep
going up Shoe Lane?
Can you cross High Holborn?
I'm crossing under
High Holborn now.
Okay, great, great.
There's an arch where I can dive.
No, there's a security guard.
I can't go in there.
You might have to take a left
until you get to Holborn Place.
Holborn Place. Okay.
Let's jaywalk.
There's a door that's
set back from the street.
Ooh, I like that, I like that.
So in theory...
I can hide against this wall and if
they go over that bridge, I've got them.
Oh, that seems very—
But they know where I am.
But also, how long
until they get here?
It may be as little as three
minutes, but it may be longer.
But they are headed directly
towards us on High Holborn.
I'm gonna go under the bridge.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna go under the bridge,
and I'm gonna tell the tracker
that I am absolutely on that street.
I am absolutely not.
In no way am I waiting on
a street below for them.
By the way, I am wide open.
If they head for Shoe Lane...
then tell me to run.
Because I am so
wide open right now.
They'll get me immediately.
Okay.
Okay, you guys are on
the same road.
You're both on
High Holborn, okay?
Okay, how long until
they turn right?
Take it basically
whenever you can.
But how long until
a road to turn right?
Well, you passed Holborn Place.
Oh, so that's what I
was supposed to take?
Yeah.
Oh, we gotta go
back there then.
I thought you were
just vibing out.
No, you're telling me, Ben.
You gotta tell me which way to go.
Okay, turn back around.
Go down Holborn Place.
I'm turning back around.
Two minutes,
I'm gonna have to move.
There's a cubby-hole—
Oh, they're moving away.
They're moving away from us.
Looks like they're moving away
from High Holborn back down.
They're headed west now.
Okay—
What are they doing?!
They've chickened out, I think.
I keep promoting NordVPN here,
in part because I keep
finding new uses for them.
Sure, I can tell websites and apps
that my computer and phone
are in some other country.
I've talked about that before.
But the other week,
I was using Wi-Fi on a plane,
and they had blocked
YouTube entirely.
Okay, they wanna stop people
using too much data, sure.
Except I didn't want to watch stuff.
I just wanted to check that a
new video had launched properly.
So I clicked a button and NordVPN
created a secure tunnel from my
laptop through to their servers,
and I could get my work done.
You may have other things that
you want to access past filters,
or as if you're in one of
about 60 other countries,
but for me, NordVPN just keeps
being helpful for my job.
It'll work on Windows, Mac,
Linux, iOS, and Android,
and on up to six devices
at the same time.
There's also a 30-day
money back guarantee
if you wanna test it out first.
If you go to
nordvpn.com/tomscottplus,
you'll find the best deal
they're currently offering.
Now, if I remember right,
I was trying to avoid
heading into Sam's trap.
Okay, I'm taking this left.
It's not a road, it's just
a pedestrian passageway,
so it might not show up as big.
Is it like Lit— It's, yeah.
It's called Little Turnstile.
Sure, yeah.
Yeah, hopefully that—
I think that can bring
you down to the park.
You know, what should
we just chase them?
I would say chase 'em.
I say go.
Go down High Holborn
and see where we can get.
I can see I'm on
the corner of a park.
Yeah, that's, that is...
That's the one?
the park.
Okay, so which direction
should I go
to be on the opposite
side of Tom?
You are on the opposite
side of Tom right now.
He's heading towards a field.
I can't really tell if that field
has elevation on it.
What's the name of it?
Lincoln's Inn Fields.
Do you know that?
Lincoln's Inn Fields
is a park.
Right.
So it's very wide open,
but it does have a lot
of things to hide behind.
If he wants to force a showdown,
that's not a bad place to do it.
It's showing that there's
a little restaurant in the...
Oh, I think I see that.
Maybe you could use that.
Yeah, he probably wouldn't...
Do you think they would
know that that's a building?
I feel like I'm walking into a trap.
I'm concerned that they
seem to have a strategy,
and it feels like we
no longer do.
Yeah, well we had a strategy,
which was like,
get close and panic them.
And I guess that worked,
because they ran!
(laughs)
Here's the good news.
They appear to be camping,
and we are not,
which means that
their camping clock
is going to end
before ours would.
Tom is now heading south.
South?
Okay, along the—
in the park or along the road?
He's still a block from the park,
so I think he might be trying to
enter the park from the south.
Huh, what do you think
we should do then?
Well, it might be worth...
Well, I guess let's
just see what he does.
Should we just go to the
other side of the park then?
Yeah, let's continue...
I think we should circle it.
We're starting to get into
what my father calls
rubber pants time.
Okay.
The British equivalent
will be squeaky bum time.
(belly laughs)
That is just fantastic!
Sam is pulling some shenanigans
like he does on Jet Lag: The Game,
where he's found some
little loophole
that he thinks is valid in the rules.
(laughs)
"Oh yeah, you could only stay
in one place for three minutes.
But I'm going to different corners
of Lincoln's Inn Fields."
'Cause I still like
our defensive strategy.
I still think it's the right strategy.
but eventually we're just
gonna have to change gears
and maybe go on the offensive.
Well, we could start
heading towards him,
but that's gonna put
us at a disadvantage.
That's risky, yeah.
This is clearly a trap.
But also, we know that.
And we know he's in
the middle of the field,
so is he going to—
as soon as we approach,
he's going to sprint for
whichever corner of the field
I'm approaching from
and try and get me first.
Right.
So instead...
do I just get to the
closest corner and try and get
a really long shot of him
standing in the middle of a field?
So I'm gonna just stand
in the middle here for now,
and then I think maybe
retreat to one of these
kind of big, wide trees
that we can hide behind.
I don't like that my
"let's aggressively
chase them down" idea...
That's Lincoln's Inn Fields.
Alright, I can...
Hang on, hang on, hang on.
I'm gonna dive for hiding here.
Hold on.
Okay, how far are they from
the perimeter of the park?
About a quarter block.
A quarter block.
Okay, I need to hide then.
But you're on the
opposite end of the park,
so I think you're fairly safe.
Yeah, it can be fairly open.
Okay.
Oh?
Okay, the tracker is a bit off,
which is interesting.
Okay, now—
Wait, okay.
So where do they think I am?
Where do they think I am?
They should think that you're further
down the street than you are,
so they shouldn't realize
you have a sight line.
Okay, in, in, in, in now?
Yeah, run in now and see
if you can get them before
they realize that you're there.
Okay, they may be
entering the park now.
It appears they may
have entered the park.
Okay.
Are you hidden?
Be prepared.
I'm hidden behind one of the big trees.
They're directly in the middle,
a little bit northwest—
Northeast, northeast,
a little bit northeast.
There should be a
large sort of
house of some kind.
I see it.
There's some tennis courts.
and then there should be
a sort of a clubhouse.
And I'm thinking that
that might have potential.
Yeah.
They are just your northeast.
They're in the middle,
to the northeast.
You are both in the park.
You should be able to
see them at any moment.
There's foliage everywhere.
Okay, okay, that's
[half as] interesting.
You should have your camera
absolutely ready to go.
I would hide
behind that clubhouse.
They should be directly to
your right, potentially.
They're hiding right at
the corner of the restaurant.
Oh, I see something red.
Is it Tom?
Oh no.
That's gotta be Tom, right?
Even a red shirt isn't identifiable.
I've got the camera app
open and zoomed in.
They're headed northeast.
They're headed to the—
They appear to be headed potentially
towards the northeast corner of—
Wait, I think that they're
directly in line with you.
They should be directly to your
right as far as I can tell.
Wait!
All the way across the field.
Okay.
Just stay covered.
Stay very covered.
I am doing, I am doing.
Because they are here.
Where are they then?
They're...
still on the sort of...
western side of the restaurant.
Now they're going alongside the
southern edge of the restaurant.
Heading towards you
to the east.
If they move west at all, let me know.
Okay.
But there is a...
There's a back route,
just sneaking down.
I'm between the clubhouse
and the tennis courts.
There is a little alleyway...
A little alleyway, okay, okay.
...that I don't think they've noticed.
Again, be really careful.
Be really careful.
They are— You're headed—
You look to be headed east.
Are you headed east?
Yeah, I'm literally going
along the tennis courts.
Oh, you're headed towards them.
You're headed towards them
if you're headed east.
Okay. They've gotta be right there.
They've gotta be right—
You should be—
I would say you're a third of the
length of the park from Sam.
He is to your east.
I'm just looking through trees.
And I assume he's gotta
be doing the same.
Can I change trees safely?
I mean, you're pretty exposed now.
They're very close to you.
Okay, let me check,
and then if not, move trees.
Ohh.
Okay, they're now on the
eastern side of the restaurant.
So you should theoretically
be able to see them.
Okay, I'm gonna
retreat one tree, okay?
Alright. Oh, I'm sweating!
Whoa...!
I had a slide out.
He's— Is there an
intersection of three paths
crossing perpendicular
in the middle of this park?
Yes.
That's where he is.
Yeah, there's a gazebo.
He's just to the east of that.
He's— I can't see him.
Why can't I see him?
I mean, I'm in a bright red T-shirt.
I've gotta be visible.
I'm gonna hide behind a hut here.
Alright, we need to develop—
Alright, let's try to
figure out a plan here.
Alright, if you see there's a—
To the northeast of the
tennis courts, there's a little hut.
Okay, okay.
I am parked, I'm on the
west side of that hut.
Okay, Ben. I have my
camera on my watch.
So my...
So I'm not exposing myself out.
Ohh!
I can see via my watch.
Sneaky!
He's northeast of that gazebo.
How the hell is he
northeast of the gazebo?
I can see northeast
of the gazebo.
He must be— I'm gonna
hide behind a tree.
Running!
I think I should move.
I'm gonna retreat to
another tree, okay?
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have no idea. Probably.
I don't know if that's him.
He's on the move.
They're running!
I've got him! I've got him!
I've got him. I've got him.
Send it, send it, send it!
It's sent. It's sent.
It's sent.
I got him. I got him.
They are the two people
hiding just there.
You can see the legs
to the left of that tree.
Got you!
You see the legs?
I see things that potentially
could be legs!
Oh, Tom got it first.
Oh no!
The red blended in much
better than I thought.
That's it right there.
Whew, incredible work, Tom.
That was all you!
I see your legs.
I really hope...
I really hope that the camera
on the GoPro caught that.
I wouldn't have known those
were your legs unless you ran.
I saw three legs there.
Oh, you got me there?
Ohh!
And I went, "Is that them?"
I mean, that was
definitely you, right?
I got your legs. That was—
No, I checked the tree.
It was the tree. That was my legs.
It was the tree. It was 100%.
Adam, how are you doing?
I am incredible, Tom.
There are few things that I
love more in the world
than for Sam to have
a complicated plan,
and then for it to fail completely!
And Ben, how are you doing?
You know, I thought we had 'em.
I thought we had set
the perfect trap.
But your damn legs are
too long and visible.
Yeah, but we had fun, right?
We had fun, so we win!
'Cause that's all that matters, Tom!
Whose idea was setting the trap?
Ben, whose idea was
setting the trap?
I would say that it was...
your producer who
came up with that idea.
Our producer?
That way no one can be blamed.
Oh, we're just blaming
it on the producer.
Oh yeah, I'm all for that.
Yeah, sure.
Got it.
Thanks for playing, Sam.
Thanks, Tom.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
Well played.